[Musique]
territoire d'info Cyril
Viguier bonjour à tous et bienvenue sur
ce plateau c'est la matinale d'info DEP
Public Sénat de Sud Radio avec la presse
quotidienne régionale et ce matin notre
invité c'est François Baayou bonjour
vous êtes le président du MoDem et vous
êtes le maire de poau et merci d'être
avec nous ce matin pour vous interroger
à mes côté Véronique Jacquier de Sud
Radio bonjour Véronique bonjour à tous
et G Lecler DEP Public Sénat bonjour
gillour François Baayou l'actualité ce
matin c'est le passage en force de
manuel Vals sur la loi travail avec
l'utilisation du 493 les députés PS
frondeur pourrai déposer une motion de
censure est-ce une preuve d'autorité ou
d'autoritarisme de la part du Premier
ministre ce qui est problématique dans
la décision que Manuel Vals a prise dans
la séquence des décisions qu'il a prise
ce qui est problématique c'est que sur
cette loi présenté comme le gouver par
le gouvernement de grande importance il
aura jamais eu de débat à
l'Assemblée le 493 c'est pas illégitime
493 ça veut dire que quand on a blocage
absolu et bien on décide de mettre en
jeu la vie même du gouvernement et de
passer c'est un des
éléments de des outils constitutionnels
qui sont à la disposition du
gouvernement en France mais là il y aura
jamais eu de débat ce qui aurait été
logique c'est qu'il y ait un débat long
qui aille à son terme lors de la
première lecture et là on
aurait user ou
épuiser tous les arguments on aurait
chacun aurait pu s'exprimer de ceux qui
sont à l'Assemblée débat dans le pays
quand mêmeend mois
vraim les les assemblées le Parlement
c'est fait pour que tous tous ces
arguments qui sont utilisés dans le pays
qu'on en tête chacun des grands courants
du pays des CIN ou si grands du pays ils
doivent pouvoir s'exprimer au Parlement
dans
l'enceinte consacrée pour cela c'est une
manière
de faire
éprouver les arguments et les
argumentaires dans le cadre solennel de
l'Assemblée quand on veut pas de débat à
l'Assemblée le risque c'est que le débat
soit dans la rue et de manière moins
maîtrisée que ça n'est ailleurs mais
vous pas répondu c'est la personnalité
du Premier ministre qui est en cause
aussi selon vous bon je pense que lui le
président de la République on décider
que il fallait avoir une séquence sur ce
texte la plus courte possible moyen en
quoi on en est à 12 manifestations parce
que quand le débat n'est pas au
Parlement je dis pas qu'il aurait dû
avoir lieu trois fois parce qu'il y a
trois lectures mais au moins une fois on
aurait dû avoir jusqu'à son terme
l'échange des arguments après le
gouvernement prend ses responsabilités
et vous voyez qu'il y a comme une
frustration par le fait que un texte
présenté comme très important ne soit
jamais examiné par l'Assemblée nationale
vous voteriez une motion de censure jaqu
bah pour l'instant il y a pas de motion
de censure et donc oui mais et
trouvez-vous normal que la droite cette
fois ne dépose pas de motion de cens
pourquoi la droite ne dépose pas elle ne
dépose pas parce que les députés
n'auraient pas été là voilà il y a pas
assez de votant à cause du match de fout
dit les déput alors vous vous rendez
compte on un parlement avec
577 membres et l'opposition le plus
important te dit non mais ils seront pas
là enfin tout ça pour vous avz pas dit
pourquoi ils serit pas là ben parce que
il paraît-il il y a l'euro ou que c'est
les vacances ou que c'est le mois de
juillet que il y a la deminale de l'euro
hein Allemagne est oui mais la
demi-finale on peut la regarder à
l'Assemblée nationale je vous assure
qu'il y a la télévision je vous assure
qu'il y a la télévision à l'Assemblée
nationale et même chacun dans chacun des
bureaux euh disons une chose qui est
très importante ceci prouve une fois de
plus quel est l'épuisement des
institution qu'on nous présente comme ne
devant pas changer auquel personne ne
touche et et qui sont mais vraiment un
théâtre d'ombre il y a 50 % des Français
qui sont pas représentés au Parlement 50
% si vous ajoutez extrême droite extrême
gauche et centre et une partie des
écologistes plus de 50 % des Français ne
sont pas représentés là où le peuple
français devrait faire entendre sa voix
et donc tout ceci est à bout de souffle
et tout ceci exige que des gens
courageux proposent le plus vite
possible et en tout cas pour les échéan
qui viennent un changement prof vous par
exemple vous seriez pour la suppression
du 493 pour que de toute façon il puisse
y avoir des débats c'est une bonne
pratique encore c'est moderne 4 moi je
je ne prétends pas qu'il faille
supprimer tous ces instruments tous ces
outils qui permettent au gouvernement
d'agir quand il y a des blocages mais il
y a une chose qu'il faut avoir en tête
un parlement qui refuse de représenter
les grandes familles politique du pays
pour donner la totalité du pouvoir à
deux familles épuisé à bout de sous
souffle en explosion
divisé ce parlement-l ne peut pas
remplir son rôle et donc il est du
devoir de ceux qui ont une vision de
l'avenir
d'exposer une autre organisation qui
fasse que la démocratie française ne
soit pas un mot ridiculisé ne soit pas
ridiculisé comme elle l'est parce que
qu'est-ce qu'il y a de démocratique dans
tout ça voulez-vous réfléchir une
seconde à la manière dont on nous a
organisé les choses qui fait que oui en
effet nous sommes à 10000 lieux de ce
que devait de ce que devrait être un
débat qui prend en charge les idées qui
sont dans le pays les jugements qui sont
dans le pays et qui à l'Assemblée
nationale leur permet de s'exprimer
alors c'est compliqué François baayot
justement à propos des familles
politiques selon le baromètre fiduciale
Ifop pour SUD RADIO François Hollande
gagne deux points par rapport au mois
dernier il est à 18 % d'opinion
favorable manuel Vals perd un point 27 %
d'opinion favorable mais surtout surtout
pour la moitié des personnes interrogées
l'opposition ne ferait ni mieux ni moins
bien donc ça vous conforte dans votre
analyse d'ouvrir une autre voie c'est
évidemment l'analyse que je porte c'est
ce que je vois c'est ce qui crève les
yeux il y a pire comme
chiffre j'ai vu il y a très très peu de
temps que si on demande aux gens si
l'opposition ferait mieux il n'y a que
19 % des Français qui répondent oui et
50 % ni mieux ni moins
bien5% bien voilà je sais combien moins
bien c'est dire à quel point on en est
de de de décomposition de tout ce
système c'est pourquoi la grande
question qui doit être posée c'est le
renouvellement de notre démocratie
française le le l'idée que il faut à
tout prix saisir les prochaines
échéances pour que quelque chose de
fondamental change dans la manière dont
les Français peuvent jouer leur rôle
pour la venir de leur pays peuvent faire
entendre leur voix peuvent être
considérés peuvent être écoutés peuvent
faire que des visages nouveaux ça passe
par la démocratie participative par
exemple oui je sais pas très bien ce que
ça veut dire la démocratie est une
participation la démocratie c'est vous
savez c'est assez simple la démocratie
signifie
que les citoyens l'opinion publique les
Français considèrent que les décisions
qui vont être prises sont des décisions
sur lesquelles ils peuvent avoir de
l'influence et aujourd'hui ils ont
aucune influence il y a même pas de
débat et donc c'est ce changement là
sans compter que peut-être on va y venir
dans une seconde le le fond de la loi
mérite une réflexion François berou
quand même si on regarde ce sondage et
si on suit vos propos si on ajoute à ça
la non candidature de Nicolas HULLOT la
relative embellie dans les sondage he il
faut être prudent de Nicolas Sarkozi on
pourrait se dire ce matin tout ça c'est
plutôt des bonnes nouvelles pour
François Baayou non dans votre démarche
dans votre réflexion pour la suite en
tout cas ce sont des éléments qui vont
dans le sens de ce que depuis longtemps
je défends devant les Français euh parce
que vous voyez bien que tous les
éléments sans boîes et sans graines il
demeure que pour l'élection présidentiel
ma ligne est claire fixée et affirmée si
Alain Jupé remporte la désignation euh
de cette primaire sur laquelle j'ai
beaucoup de choses à dire comme vous
savez avec laquelle je suis pas tout à
fait en accord si Alain Jupé remporte la
désignation je le soutiendrai pourquoi
parce que je pense que le pays a besoin
de rassemblement de gens qui disent
écoutez je ne mets pas mon propre avenir
en premier ma propre satisfaction en
premier je mets en premier ce que nous
pouvons faire ensemble pour changer le
pays et donc en revanche si Alain jupet
n'était pas choisi alors évidemment je
ferait ce qu'il faut faire alors à
propos de visage nouveau vous en parliez
vous avez l'expérience d'une campagne
électorale vous avez l'expérience d'une
présidentielle c'est très dur est-ce que
vous comprenez la décision de Nicolas
HULLOT et est-ce que ce type de profil
peut exister dans une élection
présidentielle je vais vous dire le mes
amis savent que j'ai jamais cru que
Nicolas HULLOT pourrait se présenter à
cette élection euh je pense je ne me
sens pas un destin je pense qu'il a
pensé juste d' providentiel oui je il y
a une autre phrase qui est plus juste il
a dit euh je ne suis pas assez
expérimenté et pas assez aguéri pour
occuper cette fonction ou pour être
candidat à cette fonction c'est dommage
qu'il y a pas des gens nouveaux dans le
système qui puissent rentrer non c'est
comme si vous disiez c'est dommage que
sur une route extrêmement dangereuse il
y ait pas des gens nouveaux pour
conduire le carart dans lequel il y a
les enfants à ce point-l voilà la
politique c'est ça le la politique au
niveau
présidentiel la politique dans la
fonction de Président de la République
elle exige d'avoir des gens j'espère qui
renouvelle le système qui ont une pensée
neuve mais qui ait suffisamment
d'expérience et de maturité et de et de
capacité de rassemblement c'est une
question d'ge non non c'est pas une
question d'âge fort de ce constat franis
c'est une question de c'est une question
de capacité à penser l'avenir et une
question de
vision et en même temps l'expérience de
l'État dans toutes ces dans toutes ses
couches parce que c'est pas tout à fait
rien d'avoir la maîtrise euh de l'avenir
d'un pays par délégation des citoyens
est-ce que vous en quand on vous entend
pardon quand on vous entend euh malgré
le fait que vous venez de dire que vous
seriez derrière alin Jupé on sent que ça
vous démange quand même d'incarner à
nouveau quelque chose l'expérience le
fait d'être aguéri le challenge on on
peut pas croire que vous n'ayez pas
envie d' n'est pas un problème vous avez
l'expérience d'une campagne
présidentielle euh oui euh et c'est une
expérience utile croyez-moi comment on
va le
voir je vais vous répondre simplement
euh est-ce que j'aime cette élection
oui vraiment j'ai j'ai de
euh j'ai j'ai vécu ce qu'est la
rencontre d'un candidat et d'un peuple
de citoyens et c'est tout à fait
enthousiasmant et tout à fait exaltant
cela dit je ne suis pas là pour me faire
plaisir le et c'est d'ailleurs
intéressant qu'on puisse montrer dans la
période où nous sommes que quelqu'un qui
a un socle de voix et de et d'opinion
positive et capable de dire je suis prêt
à soutenir quelqu'un d'autre je trouve
que ça apporte quelque chose enfin je
trouve peut-être je me trompe mais à la
question est-ce que vous redoutez cette
élection la réponse est non est-ce que
vous aimez cette élection la réponse est
oui est-ce que vous êes est-ce que vous
êtes inquiet pour quand même pour la
situation de la France quand quel que
soit éventuellement votre votre champion
qui peut peut-être être président de la
République demain on apprend par exemple
hier soir que François Hollande renonce
un certain nombre d'économie alors qu'il
y a des dépenses nouvelles qui ont été
engagées dire voilà quel que soit la le
gagnant est-ce que la situation du pays
pour réformer comp tenu aussi de cette
situation économique est-ce que ça va
pas être extrêmement périlleux de toute
façon alors la situation du pays est
comme vous le savez terriblement
inquiétante les les les changements
promis les on emploie le mot de réforme
c'est un mot sur lequel je je met dé
Guillet hein mais ces changements promis
n'ont pas été réalisés je veux vous
rappeler que François Hollande s'était
engagé à partir des qu et quelques pourc
de déficit que nous avions à revenir à
zéro en 2017 et évidemment nous serons
très loin d'obtenir même le résultat
qu'il avait promis pour la première
année pour 2013 alors vous voyez à quel
point tout ça la situation du pays est
inquiétante mais je vais vous dire
l'état d'esprit du pays n'est pas bon
c'est l'état d'esprit du pays qui au
fond est le plus le
plus
bouleversé et qui nous met dans une
situation difficile il y a plus
d'optimisme il y a plus de volonté il y
a plus d'esprit de rassemblement il y a
plus de sentiment national de sentiment
d'unité de la nation et c'est ça qui est
grave je vais prendre un exemple sur ce
qui va pas je voulais dire un mot de la
loi Macron du fond de la loi Macron ce
qui est pour moi le plus pénalisant pas
de la loion la loi al comerie
excusezm du travail ce qui est le plus
pénalisant dans ce texte c'est ce qui
c'est la décision qui est ouverte sur
les heures
supplémentaires c'est-à-dire qu'on
pourra les payer moins qu'on ne les paye
aujourd'hui je trouve que ça ne va pas
dans le bon sens et que c'est même
profondément choquant pourquoi parce que
la grande question c'est que les gens
qui travaillent arrivent pas à gagner
leur vie le le le problème le plus
important que nous avons devant nous
c'est des millions de personnes au
travail qui sont en situation économique
difficile et les heures supplémentaires
c'est un moyen de d'améliorer les fins
de mois or on décide de rabattre les
heures supplémentaires et c'est pour moi
ça va à l'encontre de tout ce qu'on
devrait faire on pouvait trouver un
système que j'ai proposé depuis
longtemps qui était que la prime pour
une heure supplémentaire viennent en
diminution des charges sociales donc
pour l'entreprise ça aurait été un coût
supplémentaire zéro franç je m'adresse à
à l'Européen est-ce que le brexit peut
influencer votre décision personnelle
pour porter encore ces valeurs de
l'Europe éventuellement dans une
bataille présidentielle non je vous ai
dit ce qui a influencé ma décision le
brexit ça va peser sur la campagne quel
que soit les candidat c'est une c'est
une nécessité de plus d'apporter une
vision pour l'avenir mais regardez ce
qui se passe en Grande-Bretagne
et qui est incroyable et que tous ceux
qui traitent légèrement de ces questions
j'ai vu que Madame Le Pen disait que si
elle était élue elle organiserait un
référendum de sortie et si elle le
perdait elle démissionnerait vous vousê
vous êtes pas contre référendum vous
l'avez dit le je pense au contraire
qu'il faudra associer le peuple à ce
choix mais pour moi regardez ce qui se
passe en Grande-Bretagne tous les
leaders qui ont voté pour la sortie de
la Grande-Bretagne démissionnent
pourquoi parce qu'ils veulent pas
affrontter les difficultés ils ont créé
une sit crise majeure depuis le brexit
pas de crise européenne majeure regardez
bien ce qui se passe sur le front de
l'immobilier je dis ça avec
naturellement la distance nécessaire ils
ont créé une situation qui est une
situation dommageable pour la
Grande-Bretagne et ils s'échappent parce
qu'ils ne veulent pas en assumer la
responsabilité ça devrait suffire à dire
ce qu'est ce que sont les conséquences
d'un choix qui fait bon marché de la
venir des jeunes dont je rappelle que
ils ont voté pour le maintien à 75 % un
pays qui vote contre ces jeunes a dû me
semble-t-il des questions devant lui
c'est François baayrou le président du
MoDem maire de peau qui est l'invité de
notre matinale d'info vous êtes un
aququittin vous êtes maire de peau on
sait que vous êtes proche d'Alain Jupé
même personnellement que vous
l'appréciez à titre personnel quel
conseil vous pourriez lui donner à la
fois d'amis mais aussi d'experts de
campagne électorale pour rebooster sa
campagne pour qu'il fasse la différence
notamment avec
je vais vous dire quelque chose qui va
peut-être vous surprendre j'ai toujours
appliqué dans ma vie une règle simple
quand j'ai un conseil à donner à
quelqu'un que j'aime bien je le donne en
privé et pas à la télévision parce que
quand on vient à la télévision pour
donner des conseil c'est généralement
qu'on a l'idée de ne pas rendre au
service à celui
que oui bien sûr alors deuxème chose il
faut que vous écllarcissiez les choses
pour le milieu politique et
journalistique on dit que vous avez
rencontré très récemment Nicolas Sarkozi
peut-être à sa demande d'ailleurs est-ce
que c'est vrai j'ai lu ça avec un
certain amusement je n'ai pas vu Nicolas
Sarkozi depuis des années je ne l'ai pas
j'ai pas besoin dans les yeux ma parole
est une parole je sais bien que c'est
pas fréquent dans le monde politique
mais quand je dis oui c'est oui quand je
dis non c'est non je n'ai pas vu Nicolas
Sarkozi depuis des années il y aurait
d'ailleurs pas de honte si si si je le
croise je lui ser la main je n'ai pas de
débat personnel avec lui suis en
désaccord avec sa manière d'envisager la
politique et la fonction présidentielle
bon vous pourriez le voir là dans dans
les aucune difficulté si je le croise à
parler avec lui quand je rencontre des
proches quand je vois des proches de
Nicolas Sarkozi je leur parle évidemment
comment en serait-il autrement on n'est
pas des sauvages mais le le petit bruit
dont vous venez de vous faire le relais
en disant que j'aurais contacts sec
naturellement pour éclaircir les choses
que j'auraai des contacts secrets avec
Nicolas Sar dit non il n'est pas fondé
en aucune manière merci François
baayerou président du MoDem mer deep
d'avoir été l'invité de cette matinale
d'info on passe à